all you yo Jada picket Smith is on a
[__] podcast tour that's not her but
it's on a podcast tour look like this
looks like that looks like the the the
the promotional image of every Netflix
comedy special the yes there is a lot
have you notice that there's like and
and just search for J pck Smith
interview because she did like 10 of
these there is a lot of podcasts that
have like 2 million Subs 3 million Subs
4 million Subs on YouTube shows and that
I've never heard of that I have no idea
existed but apparently are are big like
this show is the J Shetty podcast who
the [__] is J
Shetty what is J Shetty it's some again
they these Indian guys are just coming
off an assembly line he's a British he's
a British writer in lifestyle Guru
so he's a life coach so he's full of
[__] yeah but he's won 11 shorty
Awards e highlight think it's often can
be missed at least is you know when you
had that conversation on red table talk
it would have been so easy show your
chakra show me your chakra spread your
chakra for to be a baby and I'm only
raising this
because I know how much for you it was
part of the work you are doing yeah and
that's why I'm raising this because I
think what's really interesting is that
when someone's trying to do deep inner
healing work
yeah yeah I hate her Will Smith [__]
Margot Robbie
yeah actually more often than not they
remember when like remember when people
were into J pink it no I never I mean I
mean I know yes I do know people were I
said people I I remember people were not
me she never did it she was never really
there was always hotter black checks I
like of course but uh I was always more
of a uh who's the [__] that uh the one
that got became like rightwing the one
that was in Clueless Stacy Dash Stacy
Dash I was more of a Stacy Dash guy so
hot or a Rachel true remember her from
the craft black trick from the craft way
will not make sense oh yeah for sure
because it literally looks like you're
setting yourself up to fail yeah because
when you're really trying to are you
going to let her talk
Bud means yeah hold on
here this
whole thing
anymore this whole Jada will I'm done
with that it was part of the work that I
was ready for and it was what I needed
and everybody's in different places in
their Journey Journey also that's also a
dynamic I had to look at Within Myself
in regards to so it's two things there's
this healthy Jada is like tear it down I
want I don't want that Persona anymore
tear my ego down and there was this
other part of me like oh my God I need
to prot you know he's not ready no no no
no no no no people are going to hate you
cuz you're leaving Will Smith people
already hated you
Jada like Will Smith we just hate you
you
suck you know he's not ready my you know
codependency kicks in and I go this is
what I do I'm the
Martyr she's the Martyr she's basically
Jesus Christ one of the most ridiculous
things I think she's ever said she's a
martyr guys I I can do the Martyr thing
so once again it's both things it's
healing like I'm
ready like I'm ready for I'm ready for
the tear down and then this martyr
that's like and I want to make sure will
as long as you're okay I'm okay that's
part of my relationship with my mother's
addiction that so is but now what you're
saying is you don't give a [__] about
will also she's trying to equate she's
trying to equate trying to make a
marriage work with the father of her
kids to being a
martyr yeah no no no no dude that's what
she that's that's exactly what she did
she is one of the worst people for me
like I have a changing list of the women
that I hate the worst right and I I
brought this up to earlier today but
it's like the AP Top 25 college rankings
right it changes all the time it's not
like I have one person that's always up
there I think J Jada pinket right now is
the number one one I hate the most out
of all women right now she's the one I
hate the most what about the New Zealand
prime minister worse J no Jada pick it
worse worse worse worse I don't live in
New Zealand I live in America where this
[__] lives fair enough you
know we're back it is 8:14 with J pinket
Smith our wide ranging revealing
conversation made a lot of headlines we
talked about our journey from the
streets of Baltimore to the heights of
Hollywood that incident at the Oscar her
battle with severe depression her
relationship with mil Will Smith and
after all of it Jada says she's finally
feeling worthy that's the title of her
new book it's you're not you're not
you're not worthy of Love e out tomorrow
it's an incredible read it's packed with
so
much soad to see she is that's that's
the part that's but but she was never
even good no I'm telling you she was
never even good did you see I'm going to
find the one cuz she did another podcast
where she talked about Tupac like really
for way too long so after we had our
long sit down this is stuff you've been
carrying with you for many many many
years and it's out there so as we sit
here today in a reflection of was it the
right thing to reveal to talk about
everything do you feel like you made the
right choice absolutely I think you at
some point hey did will have a say in
this I'm just curious like did your
husband have a saying this and also
speaking your truth [__] your son's
friend right what part of speaking your
truth did that take it was a family
friend r a family friend oh yeah you're
right you're right you're right do you
want to hear how cool she thought she
was with tup I found it I I found the
one I was talking about she talks about
herself like she was just basically she
was Tupac another thing I learned from
reading the book which is going to shock
you that I didn't know but this shows
how little I am tuned into media and
Hollywood yeah you're better than
everybody uh the Diary of a CEO whoever
that is is your relationship with t Pac
oh yeah he comes over introduces himself
yeah first day of school Baltimore
School for the Arts and um as soon as I
walk in he's holding Court he's holding
Court he's a like he's a charismatic
from day one he's your court you don't
say yeah unlike my shitty
husband who's that peanut head dude over
there you know and I'm coming in I'm
rocking you know I'm Jada I'm walking in
I got the rat tail I got the flock but
what she thinks of herself you look look
at you're seeing it come out right like
this is who she is she does think who
the [__] she is all the time that's her
Baseline close you know and he turns and
we our eyes just meet and I'm like oh
and then you know I'm I'm going to hold
my court you know I'm saying cuz she was
also popular in case M
mer in case you didn't think she was
also popular in high school she
was how does how does Will Smith
just I don't know man how did he even
get caught up in this
mess just Tupac
died and so then he comes over you know
remember when she her
daughter her daughter Will Smith's
daughter wrote a love letter to Tupac on
behalf of her mother yes oh God you're
bringing back more nightmare [__] for we
we've been covering for actually we've
been covering uh sorry we've been
covering her for this this whole thing
for a while right and and and and the
weird [__] that comes out is like this
is a weird [__] family man like oh
okay cool yeah whatever and so he comes
over and he's like hey I'm Tupac and I'm
like Tupac the name from the gate was
just like it's a typical black name calm
down never heard a name like that before
for that was such a
powerful different name and I was like
Tupac and he had this big smile and I
was like it's not a lot of people that
have that kind of like Charisma and
courage to just walk up on me on just
like I'm Tupac I'm you know what I mean
you I actually met his cousin first
Marvin Shakur and he held the phone out
and remember that West Coast style of
rap you listen to well listen to this
and he pulled it
up you need to know so so uh he goes hi
I'm Tupac he didn't come up to you and
say hey my name is Lay Parish Crooks no
he said his name is
Tupac you know and from the right from
there Inseparable we became the best of
friends from that moment on we just
connected it was as if we already knew
each other it's
crazy people will find it hard to
believe that at that age in that
environment it wasn't a romantic thing I
know people have had had a really hard
time you know understanding that why did
your daughter write him a love letter
yeah so they why did you actually call
him the love of your life at one point
they were just they were just best
friends but it wasn't romantic what a
liar understanding
why it just didn't we didn't have it and
I talk about in the book you know that
being on the back of porch of my house
there's a black scent is coming out yeah
black scent comes she's talking about
Tupac now she's getting Hood this is
Hood Jada and we're like having this
discussion I'm like okay Pac just kiss
me and he kisses me and it's the most
disgusting kiss every time you pause the
screen she looks like another wood mask
that if you found it in the Amazon you
just know you're cursed now you want you
that's it even if you put it down and
pretend you never picked it up doesn't
matter and then Jamie Kennedy's kid gets
hit it's a whole
thing
uh so so look here's what she's doing
here I see 100% what she's doing here a
[__] why is she talking about oh yeah me
and Tupac were friends but uh me and
Tupac were friends but we never actually
[__] you're like why would you say
that because now that he's dead he can't
say yeah I [__] hit that so what he's
do what she's doing is going look at me
Tupac Shakur the guy who could have any
woman in the world I neged him I neged
Tupac he he simped for me and he didn't
even get no [__] that's EX exactly what
she's doing people have to see that
right people in the chat see that right
I'm asking you guys you see that's
what's happening here right she's doing
the like Tupac The Ladies Man the I get
around
guy that guy he not even and also and
also J to pck at the I get around woman
yeah exactly you two [__] hornballs
didn't [__] get the [__] out of
here and he kisses me and it's the most
disgusting kiss between us both I mean
he pulled back just like and I pulled
back and I was like see dummy you know
and from there it was just like and then
there was one more time he kissed me and
it was just like and I talk about that
in in jail when I go to see him and they
[__] though that she just doesn't like
kissing it's too intimate yeah she's
like a hooker yeah
Amora that's a whole another thing the
only thing she kisses is her kids on the
mouth remember that really weird stuff
with these people once again it's just
like
dude doesn't work but stop trying Tupac
Shakur I have tamed
you that's what she's
doing yeah there's something gross about
rewriting history with dead people she
wants on her record this is how this is
how needy she is cuz she sucks at acting
is she has anything recently that's been
worth a [__] I mean years so what what
she's doing is she wants to go not only
am I the person who [__] told Tupac
to go [__] himself I told Will Smith one
of the biggest actors of all time to go
punch Chris Rock and he did it and he
did it for me and then you know what I
did I still left them that's what a bad
[__] I am that's what she's doing yeah
what do they call her uh boss [__] I
called her sociopath oh okay that's
sociopath a narcissistic sociopath
someone's been reading the dsv
[Laughter]
fire
throughout our
relationship we definitely had this
beautiful
closeness yeah he was like really he
wrote me poems even though he wasn't
[__] me because a young black
teenager is going to be more interested
in writing poems to some [__] mid
[__] then [__] her you're right you're
right you're right Jada we're sure
that's what
happened what a [__]
liar you [__] Tupac and now you're
pretending you're to [__] Tupac because
you wanted to be the closest person he
ever had in his life you're just mad
that he wrote a song Dear Mama and not
dear
Jada yeah that's going to be her next
thing she's going to be like keep your
head up what's written for me it was me
actually was really
intimate but never physically
intimate lot of emotional intim L ass
Crystal Skull ass having ass [__] yes
because young young black youths are
known for having intimate relationships
with black
women in
school a lot of forget that me I'm
thinking of me in high school right do
you think I was going to want to have a
a deep intimate relationship with some
[__] I wasn't trying to [__] get the
[__] out of here no I was horny [__]
[__] shut
up um intellectual intellectual cuz
she's
smart can't write a script or direct
remember when she [__] got completely
panned for a Cleopatra thing she tried
to make on Netflix and everyone was like
she wasn't black you're insulting us she
can't write a script she can't read a
script
no but she can get them filled that's
for
sure look at those
pupils see um
we just knew how to reach each other in
ways that was very difficult we knew how
to get around each other's wall that's
why I get around was really about the
way we got around each other that song I
get around was actually deeper than it
was song is actually about how I get
around FS I yes
exactly and we didn't get offended when
we would fall into our default faults of
Defense which could be pretty Fierce
between the two of us they were like
equals they were like you know you know
when the two greats are battling at the
top you know everybody always thinks
like you know was [__] Tupac Biggie
Jada everybody says that tup big J yeah
everyone knows bro everyone that's why
you always see her airbrushed on the
murals with them yeah no you got
basically the same didn't she have a
band that
sucked she's done it all and sucked it
at all mhm try marriage
um parenting not [__] her son's
friends all you have to do was not [__]
your son's friends why
could Tupac loved
him wait what that's her yeah you didn't
know she was in a band you didn't know
she was in in a band okay like when you
said music like a a certain image came
you're racist yeah I was ever heard of a
little band called Nonpoint you're
racist I guess you've never heard of
Lenny Kravitz hard rocker Lenny
Kravitz yeah Living Color yeah no hey he
was half black and half white you can't
call them that stuck Mojo oh yeah mhm
mhm what about them you idiot it huh
that's right it's what I thought that's
about it though I can't think of anymore
the only one I knew was hoodie what
about the people that wrote Le ze's
music Darius Rucker by the way he's not
hoody his name is Darius Rucker that
nigga's name is Hoody it's Darius hoody
Rucker let's be honest do you think
there's anyone that Jada pinket hates
more if you think about it than Darius
Rucker and hi Berry Oh no you're right
it she absolutely 100% cuz she's just
the RC Cola brand of Halle Berry yeah
yeah dude she is like two years ago she
had her new song J so it's not even like
she this is not like old that old of
music or she's still trying the name of
her band is wicked
wisdom
[Music]
ew
this completely different
vibe black Incubus ladies and
gentlemen oh my God it
is this sounds like if you were going to
start this sounds like if you're were
going to start an Evan Essence cover
band and everyone in the band is named
Kevin and you call it Kevin
as
[Music]
break me down Wake me up
inside this is Atlantic recording artist
hailstorm this is the Atlantic Atlantic
Records recording artist hail stor it's
more like
[Laughter]
mudslide oh
[Music]
[__]
wasn't this ban like all black people
too yeah it's all black people that was
always cringy to me too like like I know
you know it's like whenever I'd see like
a metal band right and it would have
like one black guy in it and he was just
like killer on [__] guitar or Basse
be like a that's cool yeah but whenever
but it feels like a gimmick right when
you're like we're gonna get all black
guys in a metal band it's like all right
you're doing a gimmick though yeah when
I see all black guys in a band they
better be singing Earth Angel mhm they
better be they be sharing one microphone
yeah exactly and
being thank
you the silver one with the grill yeah
exactly oh
[__] this is really bad yeah I know very
bad and in every way like holy [__] bro
this sounds like a band warming up Tim
is better than this yeah yeah it sounds
like this sounds like a sound
[Music]
check dude it's not even in sync no it
sounds like when the band lits it's not
even 98 Degrees MCH no it sounds like
they're all playing a different song
yeah mer it sounds like when a band lets
the Ries do the sound
check wow they're not good at at all
like this is the final recording and
you'd hear mess ups in
it how much of Will Smith's money did
this
cost I mean I'm not going to say it was
a big movie but at least After
Earth hey play that open drop D again
buddy you should do that again do that
some more I mean [__] Jay say what you
want about w w West at least that song
came back in the black I mean you know
at least we made our money back that's a
good point it made money it made
money
that's why she looks like Cisco
now wow this so bad it's really
bad yeah this is not good and I mean
look I will admit that this also is not
my genre generally shitty
music dog [__] [__] no but I mean you
know that that kind of [__] whaling
yeah like fly had stab wounds mhm yes
and look look I did a show and worked
with fly leaf and I hate that little
[__] [__] but you know what I'd
rather listen to fly leaf than this
[__] you know I had to talk about my
journey you know and um I think just
like we were talking about I think
there's so many of us who you know can
modern women stop talking about their
Journey all right if I want to hear
about a journey I'll read about Lewis
and Clark you dumb [__] or Listen to
Don't Stop believe
there you go with the new Asian singer
who sounds better than the original guy
super weird he does super weird really
good you know specifically women and
feeling like we're going to be
criticized we're going to be judg you
can't say anything no no no no no
no no you're not being criticized cuz
you're a woman you're being criticized
cuz you're an insufferable woman yeah
you are you're a dumb [__] women don't
like you either she this isn't like one
of those situations where women like
love Taylor Swift and men don't get get
it and hate her that's not one of those
situations men and women hate you the
Jada J Jada pck Smith is some like I
don't understand who's buying her book
who's uplifting her who sits back after
everything and goes you know who I
really like Jada nobody
nobody yeah you're not even you're not
even ranked in that people like your
kids more than you yeah no absolutely
and they made a new Karate Kid yeah your
daughter actually had a successful uh
one successful single so she's your
daughter had a more successful um music
career than you and your son has a more
successful overall career than you well
she's just upset she can't she can't
whip her hair back and
forth part about it Willow taunting her
mom yeah this whole journey as difficult
as it's been has just so [__] stupid
bro and it was I can't believe that that
shit's sold closer that was the side of
our crumbling Nation right there I went
my hand
[Laughter]
such an authentic way you know instead
of trying to be a thing it's like just
tearing all that down and finding what's
true between us wow and it's been
beautiful it's been difficult it's been
difficult but beautiful so now you're
going to have another sexist
relationship with a former rapper sounds
great sounds [__] great one thing
people were really still concerned about
or confused about really was okay hang
on they've been divorced in theory but
not on paper yes they've been you can't
be divorced in theory yeah you can't be
figuratively divorced you are or you
aren't they were not together but kind
of pretended they were together so I
hope the IRS comes after them for tax
fraud I had trouble articulating exactly
why that was so now that looks like a
well-maintained skin Bandit
yeah more time was that we really needed
time to get solid [__] the peeling
machine behind the [__] green screen
yeah because at the end of the day day a
new layer will and I love each other you
know we had to really figure out what we
wanted you don't love anything you don't
love yourself you're not capable of love
you are diagnosa
Psychopathic we went into the world to
say what was going on because we were in
such you know we were just kind of in
this very fragile place and so now we're
just super solid yeah and so now I can
actually talk about what the journey has
been so will talked to the New York
Times or gave a statement and this is
what he says leave me alone man we'll
put it up on the screen this is from the
times itself the Memoir Will Smith said
in an email kind of woke him up she'
lived the life more on the edge than he
had realized and that she is he said
that it was a learning experience for
him yeah she is more resilient clever
and compassionate than he'd understood
and this is the quote when you've been
with someone for more than half your
life he wrote a sort of an emotional
blindness sets in and all you can do uh
and you can all too easily lose your
sensitivity to their hidden nuances and
subtle
Beauties
no what she cucked you she cucked you
like three times in public and you're
saying she's beautiful I don't feel bad
for will I don't he did this to himself
and honestly why is the New York time
reading it what wouldn't it be more
powerful if he showed up with you you
you know why you know why cuz Jada wrote
that oh yeah did it sounds like an
emotional blindness he didn't see you is
that kind of what it was that he I think
yeah that's so Universal in
relationships he didn't see me and I
didn't see him right and so we kind of
what does that mean psycho
Babble Dude That's All Therapy talk dude
we talk about it all the time it's just
therapy
talk none of this is real hey let me
break it down for you just communicate
it's real easy be honest don't expect
someone to read your hidden nuances like
you said there don't expect some guy to
understand the hidden meaning of you to
read what not what you said but what you
meant because no most dudes are [__]
literal okay tell them what you want and
you will get what you want but all this
it wasn't what I said it's not what he
said MCH it's what it's what like will
didn't
say shut up yeah she's just I I if I
never saw this woman again I'd be so
happy oh my
God uh the shadow band I find it very
offensive that Jada's cosplaying is the
dolly
llama
uh Jack cat people forgot that Tupac was
gay [__] ballerina dancing Art School
homo before Jay's got a hold of him with
a new image for him uh true Jack cat I
believe they didn't have sex Tac was gay
oh you already said that uh Irish
serpent uh Jada's new single I whip my
wig back and forth uh true
wolf took a second trolf says fly leaf
has three okay songs is barely mid
Virg's drunkenly finger [__] his
guitar plays better music uh don't give
I hear you but do not give Virgie
compliments don't
I told you we're we're tra we're cray
training him so I found something really
[__] funny all right so 10 years ago
at an afro funk you okay Jada pinket
Smith played and with her band right
oh watch the crowd when they scan over
the crowd cuz the crowd is so confused
they had no idea
what
like
huh any white people you see there or so
they could say later brag and say they
went to an afro funk festival of
course oh also J doesn't even come on
stage till like halfway through this
[Music]
video
why is the security guard in a tuxedo
everything about this is
weird yeah also where's the
br oh
God for give me for all the [__]
that was so B although I had f hey you
guys do sound
[__] her vocals are like twice as loud
as everything else over the PA well you
know she insisted on
that hey you think the B Line's drowning
out my
vocals yeah her band just sounds like a
karaoke track yeah a MIDI karaoke track
I'm just thinking a d dark though when
he's in the studio he's like I think the
bass is trying to drown out my voice
he's like no I think I know what I'm
doing now turn the bass down some more
Jesus [__]
Christ all right listen Rage Against the
washing machine nobody nobody [__]
cares about what you're trying to do
she's been every song that we've heard
she's been trying to sound like a
different band there isn't even a
consistency in Her Style no it's just a
mishmash of like early 2000s
rock is what it sounds like she is the
epitome of every like Rich La white
woman who like just gets indulged by her
successful husband like first they take
up pottery and they suck at it then they
start a band and they suck at it and
they try to do art and they suck at it
and it's like this this poor guy is just
constantly renovating that extra room
God for her new for whatever her new
projects are she's [__] terrible
she's the worst
human